today baseball celebrates his life and
legacy an mvp a 15-time all-star and
winner of 12 gold gloves his on-field
greatness was equally matched by his
incredible humanitarian spirit
the 2020 roberto clemente award
recipient is josh bell
josh congratulations on this honor and
thank you today teams around major
league baseball honor the legacy
established by roberto clemente as we do
at home wearing 21 proudly on our
uniforms for the first time in pirates
history t brubaker making his sixth
start his eighth appearance and he faces
the white sox
and a called third strike rondahl
shot dane dunning goes to the mount for
his fourth start as era a touch below
four as you can see good control a lot
of strikeouts
to third moncada to madrigal the turn is
a double play here is james mccann
james mccann fly ball center field
reynolds back at the wall it is gone
bring him almost to shrubbery one
nothing sucks
in one swing there went the no hitter
there went the perfect game there went
the shutout and there went a tie game
sox on top one to nothing james hits his
fourth drives in his ninth keeps his
batting average over 300 and that's a
good way to start it off
hanging breaking ball joanne spikes it
into right field and a little bobble
from polanco yowan decides to break for
second base and he is in there safely so
yuwan aware of the bobble by polanco
gets to second
this heads up base running because if
you go to first aggressively and take an
aggressive turn then when the fielder
juggles it at all you just take off
polanco has some problems
then has some more problems by the time
he finally rights the ship
there is no chance to get mongkot at
second gotta go base hit e9 so yazmani
grandahl at the plate
and there's a drive up the middle base
hit center field rounding third on his
way toward the plate as moncada he is
going to score the white sox have taken
a two nothing lead yasmani grandahl
drives in another run his 21st of the
season two nothing socks here in the
fourth he beat the shift so it's up to
james mccann base has loaded one out
center field on a line reynolds is there
to make the catch rondale tags from
third throw goes toward third the sox
get another run
that's three nothing here in the fourth
[Applause]
so the bags loaded once again for
madrigal with two outs great to cash in
one maybe two more runs if you want to
get greedy here
i like being greedy i've heard about
that
only in certain situations
there comes the one-two pitch and that's
a ground ball sharply back up the middle
into center field to base hit
here comes debrew to score right behind
him will be eloy jimenez he will score
it's a two-run single nick madrigal it's
now five-nothing white sox here in the
fourth
so nick continues to hit in the clutch
and he is somebody that is making
everybody sit up and take notice he is
no easy out as you've already pointed
out in the last couple of days
especially with two strikes on him he's
really dangerous then using all four
quadrants with it
he gets a lot of people out they don't
square it up too often
tapper third base side monkada's got a
hurry oh what a play
i mean he got him by a long step or two
on an effort that should have been bang
bang that's a whale of a play i think a
lot of people were surprised last year
that monkatta was among the best
defensive third baseman in the american
lane
he's a unique third baseman for the
simple reason that anything off balance
anything on the move any play that he
has
if he's moving he'll make a perfect
throw sucks learned a very valuable
object lesson in the game last night
you got to keep adding up that ball's
waylaid stop the conversation it is out
of here bring him home again for the
second time tonight james mccann
as soon as that one hit the bat
everybody including brubacher knew it
was gone
he just dropped his head the sound was
there
when you put the bat on the ball
it counts here's one caught up in
montana inside out swing down the left
field line that's a fair ball into the
corner
rounding third on his way to the plate
as mazzara he's going to score anderson
is stopping at third
so an rbi double for
johan monkatta down that left field line
here in the sixth inning it's now eight
nothing white sox
that one is in the air to left center
field pretty well tagged heading over
there in the alley now is eloy jimenez
making a running catch in the alley so
jimenez tracks that one down and the
inning has come to an end
one and two and you wonder well gonna be
catchers interference so the buyers will
score a run talk about
scoring unusual runs here
steve seashek comes on for the 19th time
at zra
587
in the center roberts slides in to make
the catch terrific play and you just
kind of take these for granted
in the air left field eloy jimenez
squeezes the final out and the sox win
in pittsburgh